we did here in Arizona and you know that
Las Vegas knows how to do big events we
just it seems less than a year that we
were there for the draft last fall we
had the Pro Bowl just a week ago and
they really have done an extraordinary
job understanding
how we want to present the NFL in that
Community but more importantly how to do
it Las Vegas style and they know how to
do these things and so we look forward
to working very closely with them and
working with their host committee and
their convention visitors Association so
to introduce Steve Hill who is the
president and CEO of the Los Angeles
excuse me Las Vegas that would be a
mistake we are not going there yet just
to be clear Las Vegas Convention
visitors bureau so Steve we look forward
to working with you likewise
commissioner
good morning everyone thanks for being
here
you know the commissioner said we're on
the clock we know that and usually that
is a term that the commissioner uses at
the draft and if we had a draft choice
right now I think we'd pick Jay
we would uh
yeah that's good to know
the job that Arizona has done over the
past week is hard to appreciate until
you start to try and plan a Super Bowl
in a city
um everything that it takes and it was
mentioned here but what you're actually
doing that work when you're actually
thinking about all the different aspects
that it takes in order to put on a
spectacular Super Bowl
we now appreciate that in Las Vegas and
so we have a heightened level of
appreciation of what Arizona has
accomplished over the past week you know
we come into these things pretty
confident we as the commissioner says we
know how to do events in Las Vegas we'd
feel a little more confident if you
hadn't done quite as good a job set the
bar exceptionally High
we wanted to acknowledge that if you
haven't had an opportunity to pick up
the Arizona Republic today please do our
acknowledgment of both the help that
Arizona has provided to us and the job
that they did this week has recognized
there
we also want to invite you to be at a
Las Vegas style reveal uh here at nine
o'clock I don't know if you notice the
truck out front but uh it's hard to miss
and we'd like to invite you to come out
there at nine
um we are very cognizant and I've said
this often publicly that we have one
opportunity to get the first Super Bowl
in Las Vegas right we are going to work
very hard we have an exceptional team
we've been working to do this for 60
years so we are excited about the
opportunity we excited we're excited
about the team that we have put together
in Las Vegas in order to make this
happen and I'd like to take the
opportunity to introduce you to the CEO
of Allegiant Airlines who is also the
chair of our host committee Murray
Gallagher
[Applause]
good morning everyone
it's great to be here and Jay
congratulations I'm a novice at this
I've been in business many years but
this is not business this is an event
and uh one top one-off events are
amazingly interesting to watch from afar
so to speak unfortunately or fortunately
I'm going to be right in the middle of
it next year and I can't be more excited
about the team that's going to be
putting this together you see a number
of them up here it's a tough act to
follow but I put these guys up against
it you know competition is a wonderful
thing it brings out the best in all of
us
um we want to I personally want to thank
our host committee already they've been
here for over a week observing and doing
the things needed to learn the steps
that go into such an incredible event
um on a personal note uh we were
fortunate enough to work with the
Raiders to put our name on The Stadium
Allegiance Stadium
um it was a big bite for us at the time
but
it's paying dividends I can say that
honestly the Raiders have been a great
partner for us we look forward in the
coming year working much closer with
them as a Super Bowl host committee
they're going to be an exceptional host
as we go forward and they have a tough
act to follow but my money's on those
guys uh lastly I want to thank the NFL
for giving us this opportunity Las Vegas
is uh I think entering a new era it's
always been known as a destination for
entertainment it now can arguably claim
the best sports destination as well we
have to live up to that marker but we
I'm my money's on this group Steve and
his team the the host committee all
those are going to be great well with
that
um I want to turn it over to Sandra
Douglas Morgan Sandra is the president
of the Raiders and my vice chair on the
co-host committee Sandra
[Applause]
well good morning it is so exciting to
be here not only to represent the Las
Vegas Raiders Mark Davis and the entire
Raiders organization to welcome the
Super Bowl to our home at Allegiant
Stadium eyewitness definitely start by
thanking Michael Bidwell The Bidwell
family and the Arizona Cardinals
Organization for being such gracious
hosts to us as we transition the Super
Bowl to Las Vegas you know the silver
and black has had a long history of
fight in our blood of passion and
putting our hearts on the field for our
incredible fans and I know that Las
Vegas will do the same as a first-time
host City for Super Bowl 58. I'm
incredibly proud of my hometown of Las
Vegas and to see it transform into one
of the sports destinations in the world
our ability to host a global audience
provide the highest level of hospitality
and Infuse all of that with excitement
Glitz and glamor that naturally comes
from being in Las Vegas in one of the
greatest new football facilities in the
NFL will be an unforgettable experience
so we look forward to working with
commissioner with Peter and so many of
the great people at the NFL to make sure
that Super Bowl 58 will be an
unforgettable experience
and with that I'd like to announce and
introduce you all to the great governor
of the state of Nevada Joe Lombardo
all right it's always a great honor to
go last
so uh what a fantastic day it's such a
quiet crowd right you got to build it up
we just came off a fantastic Super Bowl
and and we should be celebrating you
guys are really stoic
foreign
ER Governor Hobbs thank you thank you
thank you for the opportunity and
commissioner thank you thank you for the
opportunity
um what a great honor to host Super Bowl
58 and it's similar to what Mr Hill said
and the commissioner said uh we know how
to do it in Las Vegas and the state of
Nevada so I have a few comments and then
we're going to get on with the ceremony
here so I can tell you
you're going to be dazzled by the lights
of Las Vegas strip that you're going to
be amazed at the world-class
entertainment
that you're going to be impressed by the
natural beauty of Nevada and that you're
going to enjoy the unforgettable Super
Bowl experience at Allegiant Stadium
thank you Morgan
but I can also tell you you're going to
enjoy a welcome like no other
our whole city is excited to welcome you
to open arms and to make sure that you
have an experience that brings you
coming back to Las Vegas
even after the Super Bowl
and with that it's an incredible honor
to say to the host committee to the NFL
and to the devoted fans from across the
country and the world
welcome to Las Vegas
we can't wait to host you the Nevada way
thank you
[Applause]
okay I think we have the very first
Las Vegas Super Bowl 58 football so we
have that over here I think uh you're
passing it over okay
can you do it
[Applause]
Center for Arizona
okay
thank you
okay good morning again
um
once again last night's game was a
thrill for everybody watching it I'll
let coach and Patrick tell you about
whether it was a thrill playing in it
and coaching in it but it really was an
extraordinary performance really by both
teams
and as I said last night reflective of
our 2022 season
incredible competition all year and the
Super Bowl was every bit of that and
reflective of that great season so
congratulations to the Chiefs and their
fans coach Reed is
has put himself in the highest
regard he always was but now with two
Super Bowl victories and a clear future
Hall of Famer hopefully that will be a
few years off because I want coach to
continue to stay in coaching but what a
wonderful job he's done and couldn't
happen to a better man so coach come on
up and get your
trophy one more time
[Applause]
so
you need the record
well listen it never gets old standing
right here this is a a great uh tribute
to the National Football League a great
tribute to the Kansas City Chiefs uh
that game last night was a heck of a
game
you really I know Philly's hanging their
head a little bit but nobody really lost
I mean there's two great teams playing
each other and
um and two great cities so I'm fond of
my time there and uh I'm fond of my time
that I've had in Kansas City I the
people have been phenomenal the
organization the Clark hunts put
together
um has been a tremendous the coaching
staff the players
um you you know we've got Pat Mahomes
over here that's going to talk to you a
phenomenal phenomenal leadership
in the front office with Mark Donovan
Brad Beach
so it's a it's a good solid organization
and with good solid people and I
appreciate that having
been kind of the Elder Statesman I I uh
I appreciate all that they do to keep me
young anyways that's the time time
Jersey are we open this up to questions
okay
you uh answered the question last night
about next season but what about longer
term what what's your not holding you to
it but what's your longer term plan yeah
you know what Adam I I know I got asked
that a lot and I wasn't really expecting
to but I
um I didn't put much thought into all
that you know I
I'm enjoying what I'm doing and I'm
got this guy over here that is a pretty
good player so I mean I'm we're doing
okay
from the Sun in the UK Andy you had two
players yesterday who became fathers
obviously one's not here have you spoken
to them at all how they handled the
emotion of the day
yeah my sons are saying no two players
uh on the offense who became fathers
yesterday
yeah fathers yes yes yes yes yes I did
talk to him
um they're they're very happy and uh
congratulations to them and uh and and
their their girls there
good morning coach I'm going to stand up
for you since you told me to stand up
yesterday
hurry how much transition I mean
obviously you're going to transition to
the business side of football here after
you get back to Kansas City but how much
transition are you anticipating with
your coaching staff maybe Eric the enemy
moving on
yeah I mean listen I uh
Eric the enemies has been tremendous for
us and I think is tremendous for the
National Football League and
I'm hoping he has an opportunity to go
somewhere and and uh
and you know do his thing where he can
run the show and and be Eric the enemy
so and then after that I I don't know I
mean I don't know who is going to go I
always wish our guys the best of luck
um and an opportunity that's that's what
they what all of them deserve they work
hard and if they can get a promotion
somewhere that I can't give them more
power more power to them
morning coach Mitchell Brown kcaa uh
first of all congratulations on number
two thank you secondly on the final
drive last night what went into the
decision to play for the field goal as
opposed to just punching it in
yeah so uh we termed that church mode
and Patrick relays that we relay it's
Patrick Patrick relays it to the to the
huddle
uh you you know we knew they didn't have
timeouts we knew we could run the clock
down to eight seconds if we did it right
and still stay within that five six yard
area
um
where your physical percentages are 99
we've got a good field goal kicker so uh
and then you don't really give them much
of an opportunity to get the ball back
so
we practice this we practice it every
Friday you don't get to use it very
often but
on the biggest stage we're able to use
that yeah
Andy it seems like you enjoy the the
grind of your job for better for worse
more than you ever have the the X's and
O's the the dealing with young men is
that true do you feel that way and why
or why not yeah well I I do enjoy that
part that's the fun part of it I enjoy
having the coaches that I have uh that I
can interact with
on both sides of the ball and um but I
spend more time with the offensive guys
and to be able to come up and create
things with them and they're as much of
uh the creating process as I am so
um
Joe blaymeyers I mean the names go on
Greg Lewis
David Girardi Corey mate I mean these
guys love getting in
and and going and Tom Melvin who's been
with me since he was a player at San
Francisco State I mean always comes up
with one or two things
um you know a week and so uh and then
the phenomenal job that Andy Heck does
with the with the offensive line
and if I'm missing somebody uh
that I mean you know it's a great group
of young guys
and they're smart and I I enjoy being
around them
thank you
foreign
to the Pete Brazil Trophy winner MVP uh
Patrick Mahomes
you know all the incredible
accomplishments
um beyond the accomplishments on the
field he's one of those great young men
that you're so proud of the things he
does off the field
uh even exceed the amazing things he
does on the field
he's joined an incredibly Elite group he
is
among a very small group of quarterbacks
or players that have won the NBA Super
Bowl MVP multiple times
I think he's now in a very elite group
with respect to winning the Super Bowl
MVP and the MVP of the NFL in the same
season I believe all of the other
winners of those two in the same season
are all Hall of Famers which tells you a
little bit of where Patrick Mahomes is
going uh and he's only 27 years old so
um we are just extraordinarily proud of
him and he deserves his trophy and uh
deserves a Super Bowl championship so
Patrick come on up
[Applause]
yeah I just want to um I was when I
first off taking in this whole year
um and everything that's came with it
man I just wanted to thank my teammates
um it's been it was a heck of a run uh
we we started out in OTAs in Dallas
Texas to then went to Kansas City
um to St Joe's
um and then um we ended up back back
here in AZ man winning the Super Bowl
and so I just want to thank my teammates
all the hard work they put in
my coaches coach Reed and all the
coaches that helped me be who I am the
Chiefs organization and my family for
supporting me every day it's been an
amazing run these last five six years
and uh let's keep it rolling um
so with that it's y'all
hey Patrick take us through what your
off season might look like because of
the ankle are you going to be able to do
a Texas thing again or OTAs you feel
like you'll be ready to go takes through
the off season in that regard
yeah I think I'll for sure be ready for
OTAs and everything like that obviously
we'll continue the rehab
um continue the treatment that we were
doing
and just give it some rest I mean I
think I think the best thing is for it
is going to be rest and just try to make
sure that when we get to otay's I'm
ready to go the only thing that might
take a take a hit as my golf game so
I'll have to take a few weeks off of
that
what was the at what point did the ankle
bother you the most and was there a play
that you know afterwards you were saying
I don't know if I can I can go the next
time
um the only time that it had the real uh
I got like uh I don't know what to say
the real hurt of the ankle was when he
when I got tackled it kind of rolled to
the outside a little bit and went to and
once you have that high ankle sprain
when any little tweak like that happens
it just really magnifies it
um so that that was I mean coming into
the game I felt way better than I did
the in the Cincinnati game and obviously
that happens there and we're able to get
that luckily we're able to get in at
halftime and get some new tape on there
and some movement to try to get some
Mobility back
um and then you just I mean you gotta I
think we we talked about my offensive
line they protected me enough where I
was able to sit in there and make the
throws so it was uh something I was
gonna play through
um but uh but I'm glad I get a little
bit of rest on it now
Sam farmer
Patrick Sam farmer L.A times can you
walk us through the the touchdowns to
kadari's Tony and and Sky Moore just
that that fake
motion and what made that so effective
yeah I think um
we uh coach Reed and
and Coach Miami and all the offensive
coaches they had a good good feel for
how they passed off their motions
they're really good at passing off
emotions going across the field and
um so we we knew that since they didn't
have that guy staying in man coverage on
the the goddamn motion that we would
have a chance of maybe getting a little
outflank where we could get it to the
guy in the end zone and
um the first one it was a great call it
wasn't even set up for that situation my
coacher and Coach the enemy and calling
in that situation to get the touchdown
and the second one we actually messed up
the formation a little bit but we were
able to you still utilize the play just
to how the play worked and I think y'all
saw me like look to the right first then
look back to the left because sky was
probably supposed to be on the other
side but he was able to do the motion
and get in the end zone and so uh at the
end of the day uh touchdowns first
touchdowns will be in the Super Bowl so
I mean that's gonna be a memory he can
have
Mike barotsky Florida national news uh
Mike Brodsky Florida national news
congratulations Patrick uh I know you
have a lot of responsibilities in terms
of appearances you're going to have to
make including a trip to Disneyland
what's the first thing you're going to
do though once you get back home
yeah once I get back home
um I'm gonna spend that time with my
family uh I haven't got to even see my
son yet because he was asleep by the
time I got home yesterday so uh spend
that time with them and my daughter and
enjoy it with them and then it's going
to be parade Wednesday and we'll enjoy
it as a team I'm sure and I'm sure the
chase Kingdom will be out there so I'm
always excited to be there with them
um and uh it'll be a heck of a run man
drafts in Kansas City as well and so
we'll get to really enjoy this uh Super
Bowl win
foreign yeah so one of my favorite story
lines do the whole Super Bowl here has
been the two black quarterbacks and then
two black fathers so can you talk about
the principles the morals that your
father instilled in you to help you get
to this stage and also what morals and
principles you'd like to pass on to your
kids yeah I think the biggest thing my
dad
instilled in me was first was to follow
your dream he said no matter what how it
looks follow your dream and work work
your tail off and have no regrets on how
you work to get to that dream
um and then I think I think second I
would just be be a great man it was
those two things always he always talked
to me about was how can you follow your
dream to get to achieve that dream and
how can you be a great man while you do
it and so that was something that was
instilled to me at a young age
by my dad and it's something I want to
instill in my daughter and my son is how
can y'all be great people that make this
make this place make this Earth a better
place uh whenever y'all leave it
last question bring us home early hey
Patrick congratulations on the MVP award
and also winning the Super Bowl last
night you mentioned that you were aware
of some of the critics during the off
season about the Chiefs team how often
do you keep receipts you know of that
kind of stuff like like a Michael Jordan
and how much of that stuff pushes you
yeah it's hard not to hear that stuff
especially in today's age and social
media and everything like that and so
you hear
um how how not good we're going to be
and all you can do is prove it on the
football field I'm not a guy that's
going to re respond and say stuff back
to people or anything like that on
social media I'm just going to go out
there and improve it on the football
field and uh once you do that there's
nothing they can really say and so um we
had we had a new team man we had a lot
of young players brev Beach did a great
job of getting a lot of great players
that contributed for us in this in this
in this game especially and I said it
before the year and I'll always say as
long as Andy Reid's coaching us we're
always gonna have a chance so uh well
I'll keep the big guy around a couple
more years at least and we'll try to be
back in this game as many times as
possible
Patrick
thank you everyone safe travels